[Music]
when you know in math and science and
physics and you know these fields
there's always a right answer you're
either you're right or you're wrong and
i actually think that teaches you some
of the wrong lessons
[Music]
i remember really vividly some of my
early violin lessons where you can get
all the notes right but that actually
isn't what mattered what mattered is
that you could
weave through the notes the emotion and
the story that the original composer was
trying to to convey and i think that was
it was really powerful lesson because i
think you know one thing that many of us
learn over time is that a lot of times
it's not about something being
clinically correct or clinically right
or exactly right it's about how they
kind of make people feel
and i think that that
definitely is true in technology and
it's definitely true in everything that
we try to build
my name is alexander wang i'm the ceo
and founder of scale ai
scale ai is the data infrastructure for
ai to power the most ambitious ai
projects in the world every organization
wants to implement ai but oftentimes the
the biggest bottleneck in their way is
being able to create really high quality
data and data sets to power that ai at
scale we sort of view data as the the
core problem of building great ai
whereas a lot of other companies view it
as an afterthought and that really
prevents ai from having sort of the
magnitude of outcomes that it's able to
have
we've raised over 600 million dollars to
date and we work with everywhere from
the largest automakers in the world like
toyota and general motors to the united
states department of defense to some of
the largest enterprises in the world
like microsoft square and paypal and
some of the leading ai research
organizations like openai
when you learn how to program for the
first time it's
it's kind of shocking but you actually
are generally sort of telling the
computer to do very simple things the
art of programming traditionally is the
art of sort of giving computers very
black and white instructions very simple
instructions that anybody could follow
and one of the the beauties of ai is
that you actually have the ability to
program computers with judgment and with
reasoning and with sort of
nuanced understanding of the world and
so you can have an ai system look at an
image and tell you what's in the image
or
listen to an audio snippet and
understand what's being said and it is
sort of this
incredible enabler for
what computers can do or the power of
computing and in general i think we've
already seen
sort of over the past many decades what
the power of
computers and computing and mobile
phones and all that stuff has been on
humanity and i think ai and machine
learning has a huge opportunity to do
the same
both my parents are physicists and i
grew up in the small town in new mexico
called los alamos new mexico where
there's a national lab
and a lot of the people i grew up with
had parents who were scientists of some
sort it was a sort of very special place
and my mom from very young age taught me
about math and physics and science and
you know she taught me with such wonders
i was really impatient as a kid i think
i always
wanted to be
learning more or i always want to be
doing more always wanted to sort of be
accomplishing more and so i actually uh
i left high school after my junior year
of high school and then
moved out to silicon valley to work as a
software engineer i learned so much
about building products about
about what it meant to
sort of like be metrics focused and data
focused and what it sort of meant to
build great software and then uh that's
when i was inspired by ai i sort of saw
it in my daily work i was like ai's
really cool and i went back to mit and
then after about a year of mit i dropped
out to start scale we have over 500
people now so um it's it's pretty insane
to watch
you know what originally started as a
you know few people in a in the basement
of our investor to
what it's what it's sort of become
where we started was uh in autonomous
vehicles and self-driving and i think it
was one of the first real use cases and
applications of ai that i think caught
the imagination of the world you know
what if we could have
unlimited easy
uh eco-friendly transportation
everywhere in the world uh through
autonomous vehicles
one of the examples that
we get really excited about is in
healthcare in healthcare there's a huge
bottleneck in
the number of doctors trained doctors
all around the world and there's
incredible potential for
ai and machine learning to actually
analyze as many of the cases as possible
automatically before
needing escalation to a doctor so the
doctors can spend their time on cases
with anomalies or erratic data or
whatnot and so at scale we actually did
research with mit on using ai and
machine learning to analyze dermatology
uh data and dermatology imaging to see
how ai can actually automate that
process and then therefore unblock the
sort of doctor bottleneck
another use case that that i'm really
passionate about is using ai to help
solve some of the largest geopolitical
problems and working with governments in
being able to sort of provide technology
to aid in some of these very tough and
tricky situations
in the war with russian ukraine we
actually
deployed scales technology in
understanding satellite imagery of major
ukrainian cities uh kharkiv kiev and
nipro
to understand what was the amount of
damage in key parts of these cities and
so we we analyzed using machine learning
as well as satellite imagery and
identified uh
all sorts of structures in these cities
where there was meaningful damage that
wasn't otherwise uh being addressed or
captured by humanitarian efforts and so
i'm incredibly excited by our work there
and actually enabling sort of
humanitarian efforts enabling us to
respond to some of the world's
most pressing and exigent
problems
in the world of ai there's i think a lot
of very smart people but who are focused
you know so far out in the future that
it's almost unhelpful you know there's
so many people focused on what's going
to happen when we have agi or what's
going to happen you know two or three
decades in the future and i think
there's not enough people who are really
focused on
what are the problems that we have today
and how can we use artificial
intelligence and machine learning to
really changed the game today and so um
i think what's next for us is to be
the people some of the people hopefully
in the world who are focused on how do
we solve some of the biggest problems
today around climate around agriculture
around geopolitics around medicine
and really
start making an impact you know now
[Music]
you